welcome everybody good afternoon it's a
pleasure to be here to welcome Michael
Walzer back for the third of his four
lectures on the subject of whatever
happened to national liberation from
time to time graduate students come and
say to me that they want to work on the
subject of nationalism and I generally
advised him that this is not a good idea
because just about anything that anyone
could possibly say about the subject of
nationalism it's almost certainly being
said and it would be very unwise
therefore to try and get involved in a
PhD dissertation on a subject of that
sort and that might be good advice for a
graduate student but I think that it's
it's a testimony to the fact that
Michael Walzer is one of among other
things it makes many distinctions one of
the most creative political theorists of
our generation broadly construed that in
fact he's been developing an account of
national liberation that truly is
innovative it is an argument that I have
never heard before and he in his first
lecture when he talked about the paradox
of national liberation India Israel and
Algeria he really crystallized this the
paradox that national liberation
movements tend to be secular in their
motivation and in their anticipated
effects but produce at a downstream
reaction against the secularism
that was part of what motivated their
leaders he dug into that paradox in the
case of Zionism in the second lecture in
a remarkably thought-provoking and
illuminating way again you would think
if is if anybody
was to say that something new would be
said about Zionism and the
israel-palestine conflict at this time
in evolution of witnessing and thinking
about that subject
one would have to be skeptical but
indeed I think his pursuit of that
paradox in the context of the the
challenges that Israel now finds itself
confronting was indeed novel and
illuminating today he's going to
anticipate criticism of that thesis that
he's been developing in his lecture his
third lecture on on the subject of the
paradox denied Marxist perspectives
Michael thank you so the the the paradox
with which I began these lectures has to
do with the tense relationship of
liberators and the people they aim to
liberate and actually do liberate this
is simultaneously a relationship of deep
sympathy and deep hostility sympathy
because the liberators don't just resent
the foreign rulers and hope to replace
them they really want to improve the
everyday life of their people the people
with whom they identify their people the
possessive pronoun is important
hostility because at the same time they
hate what they take to be the
backwardness ignorant specific and
submissiveness of those same people they
want to help them by transforming them
by overcoming or modernizing their
traditional religious beliefs and
practices to which of course many of
them most of them are deeply attached
and the position that I implicitly and
occasionally explicitly defended in the
first two lectures is one of sympathy
for this transformative enterprise
coupled with Critias
some of its harsher more singular and
absolute versions I should add that in
two of my three cases India and Israel
it really can't be said that the rule of
the liberation militants after
independence was particularly harsh in
comparison say two accounts of political
harshness in the morning newspapers on
pretty much any day this year
Israel imposed military rule over the
Western Galilee and it's mostly Arab
inhabitants Nehru ruled with force in
Kashmir and in Nagaland and other
provinces of the Indian Northeast but by
world standards these were liberal
regimes with opposition parties a highly
critical press and free universities
indeed a contemporary Indian sociologist
criticizes neighbors refusal to use the
coercive powers of the state to hasten
the secularization process Nehru was too
much a liberal on this view or he was
too optimistic about the decline of
religion he invites comparison with
Lenin and Ataturk says this critic and
if you allow dictatorship suffers by the
comparison well I don't allow
dictatorship and have been hinting at a
very different critique of the
liberation militants they didn't
acknowledge the substantive seriousness
and strength of their traditionalist
opponents and begin a process of
engagement and negotiation with them but
I agree that it's entirely appropriate
to be skeptical about this position
after all the militants who did try to
engage with the traditions of their
people rather than simply negate them
were not successful in any of the cases
I'm considering they could not resolve
the paradox of national liberation nor
could they ward off the religious
revival
before asking again how one might deal
with the paradox I need to consider two
alternative accounts of national
liberation and I'm going to focus on
alternative accounts of Indian national
liberation marxist and post-colonial
list which deny that there is a paradox
to deal with on these views the aging
militants of the liberation movements
should not be surprised by the religious
revival for they are its direct cause
revivalists religion is as an indian
friend said to me the dark twin of
national liberation the opposition on
which i have focused is only a surface
phenomenon a mere squabble between
social forces that are whatever they're
militants and true believers think world
historical allies the marxist account
holds that religious identities are an
example of false consciousness they are
pre-modern and anti modern and not
usefully engaged with the real world
the liberationists failed to overcome
these identities because their own
nationalism is also an example of false
consciousness and it is also pre-modern
and anti modern whatever their pretended
opposition nationalism and religion
reinforce each other
post-colonial writers by contrast see
these two nationalism and religion as
specifically modern creations they
stress with a kind of romantic nostalgia
the fuzzy syncretistic reciprocal an
overlapping character of pre-modern
religious identities and argue that the
singular and exclusive religion that
fosters eletric is the product of
colonial rule which the liberationists
did not challenge so much as perpetuate
they the liberationists appropriate
Western forms of disciplinary power and
it
can't be surprising that Hindu militants
compete with them to exercise that power
I'm going to focus mostly today on the
Marxist critique since I find it the
more challenging of the two I will say
something about post colonialism at the
beginning of my next lecture
the Marxist critique begins just as I
began with a nation whose members have
adjusted to foreign rule accepted their
subordinate roles and even found ways
especially religious ways to legitimize
their own subordination they are indeed
passive quiescent submissive they fit
the description given by the National
Liberation militants except that there
is nothing in their condition that is
peculiar to their nation in fact they
are exactly like or fundamentally
similar to subordinate men and women
everywhere and it is critically
important that they come to recognize
the similarity the sense of one's self
as the member of a subject people rights
Edward Saeed in culture and imperialism
is the founding insight of anti
imperialist nationalism but it will lead
to chauvinism and xenophobia unless the
individual member sees his own history
as an aspect of the history of all
subjugated men and women the alternative
account is a universalizing account
which denies that oppression has a
national name indians are not oppressed
as indians or jews as Jews or Algerians
as Algerians they are simply subject
people's parts of a global proletariat
and it is a mistake to think that their
liberation has to be or that it can be a
national liberation Perry Anderson the
founding editor of new left review has
it developed the most subtle version of
this argument in a comparison of
countries and movements only a little
different from my own he deals with Indy
Israel and Ireland in these three
countries he writes and I'm quoting now
the nationalist party that came to power
after independence distance itself from
the confessional undertow of the
struggle without ever being able to
tackle its legacy head-on in each case
as the ruling party gradually lost its
luster
it was outflanked by a more extreme
rival that had fewer inhibitions about
appealing directly to the theological
passions aroused in the original
struggle the success of these parties
that is the religious parties that come
later was due to their ability to
articulate openly what had always been
latent in the National Movement
but neither candidly acknowledged nor
consistently repudiated on this view the
liberators try to distance themselves
from the religious commitments of their
fellows but they don't have the courage
or because of their nationalism they
don't have the capacity to do so openly
explicitly and consistently and so
religious passion remains latent and
unchallenged in their nationalist
project in effect the militants of
national liberation create the modern
nation in much the same way as the
revivalists later on create a modernized
religion by evoking its primordial
character by searching for heroic
moments in its history and insisting at
the same time on the injuries it has
suffered at the hands of conquerors and
persecutors while they are critical of
the actual culture of their people they
recover or invent a historic culture
that they can celebrate and all this
brings with it the undertow of the old
religion so the nation becomes the
prison of its liberators and
fundamentalist religion turns out to be
nationalism secret double or for
Anderson its unchosen but inevitable
successor claiming with some justice he
said
to be its legitimate heir my friends
phrase dark twin is ambiguous for
National Liberation on this view is as
dark as religious revival the two of
them are equally parochial and exclusive
they lead inevitably to the creation of
others who are excluded from the nation
treated as enemies feared and hated they
give rise to a chauvinist and intolerant
politics of course the militants of
National Liberation have a different
view of their project many of them can
rightly insist that their repudiation of
the old religion was over many years
resolutely explicit and entirely
consistent and all of them argue that
their aim is not the aggrandizement of
their nation but rather equal membership
in the Society of Nations and
reciprocity with the others but insofar
as they are nationalists this is the
alternative view the Marxist view they
cannot achieve these goals without
mobilizing their own nation and in
practice that means appealing to blood
ties gut feelings and irrational beliefs
the liberators imitate the believers
they hope to defeat they appropriate the
religious themes of martyrdom and
vindication to come they set past and
future glory against present humiliation
and whatever they say about their goals
the political struggle they begin isn't
aimed at independence simply or equality
or religious freedom but at triumph over
ancient enemies many of whom were also
members of a different faith infidels
Andersson limits his argument to
nationalist movements and this is his
these are his words in which religion
played a central organizing role from
the start providing so to speak
the genetic code of the movement the the
biological imagery is a mistake I think
as it always is in writing about
politics but I don't disagree with
Anderson's effort to
focus the argument I'm afraid though
that many more cases than his three or
my three will have to be included most
national histories are entangled with
religious histories that's why the
militants have to work so hard at
disentanglement that's what makes
national liberation so problematic asked
by our Andre Malraux what his most
difficult task after independence had
been Nehru replied that first piously
and then realistically creating a just
state by just means he said and then
creating a secular state in a religious
country the alternative view of national
liberation holds that secularists like
Nehru weren't secular enough couldn't be
secular enough as long as they were also
nationalists inevitably the National
Liberation militants summon up the
religious zealots the doctrines changed
but the underlying parochialism and the
passionate engenders are very much alike
it follows that Gandhi's political use
of Hindu motifs is not an exception to
the general rule of national liberation
it is in fact an especially clear
example of the general rule only his
pacifism is exceptional yes as Naipaul
wrote Gandhi called up India's archaic
religious emotions but that's what all
nationalists do even when they think
they are opposing religion for these
archaic religious emotions are closely
connected to the archaic national
emotions which are the necessary
material of liberationists propaganda in
fact the two sets of emotions are in
many cases virtually identical Hinduism
as a unified and coherent world religion
standing with Christianity and Islam may
be an invention of the British the
opposition of Hindus and Muslims may in
part be the consequence of Imperial
policy it is still the case that Hindu
beliefs and
practices and Hindu understandings of
defeat and depression played a crucial
role in Indian national mobilization and
they served at the same time to remind
Hindu Indians if there was a Muslim
conquest before the British conquest
efforts to evoke the image of an
independent India inevitably look back
to the time of a Hindu Raj many Hindu
nationalists in neighbours time and
later - were not religious at all
vd Savarkar the chief ideologue of
Hindutva who invented the word wrote a
book defending the idea that Hindus not
Indians were a nation and that Hinduism
in all its varieties was simply the
culture of the nation but he also wrote
that India was the Hindu holy land which
demonstrates I suppose Anderson's
undertow and India according to Savarkar
was no one else's holy land Muslim and
Christian Indians had holy lands of
their own far away Savarkar imagined an
inclusive Hindu community he wanted to
bring in Jains and Sikhs and to bring
back men and women who had converted to
Islam or Christianity but they could
only come back if they returned to the
culture of Hinduism which was in fact a
religious culture theorists of Hindutva
like Savarkar and also the more radical
ms Goel Walker frequently compared
themselves to the Zionists who were also
asserting the claim of a nation that was
conventionally described as a religious
community the difference is that Jewish
nation hood was clear at least to the
Jews mu Sharelle the people of Israel or
the nation of Israel was the most common
name for the Jews among the Jews
themselves Hindu nation hood by contrast
was an ideological construction unknown
to most Hindus in delineating this
ideological nation
and marking its boundaries the Hindutva
theorists could not avoid religious
markers of a fairly extreme sort thus
gold Walker in his 1938 description of a
future Hindustan and I'm quoting him now
the non Hindu people of Hindustan must
either adopt Hindu culture and languages
learn and respect and hold in reverence
the Hindu religion entertain no ideas
but those of glorification of the Hindu
race and culture in a word they must
cease to be foreigners or they may stay
in the country wholly subordinated to
the Hindu nation claiming nothing
deserving no privileges far less any
preferential treatment
not even citizen rights the line from
that sort of thing to an overt religious
zealotry is easy to make out not so the
line from Congress nationalism whose
ideologues like Nehru insisted that
India was a composite and not simply a
Hindu culture not so the line from labor
Zionism either whose protagonists as I
suggested last time were not inclined to
hold Judaism in reverence let alone
require anyone else to do that there are
indeed nationalists and Orthodox as
Ellis today who would like the State of
Israel to embody the same radical
entanglement of nation and religion that
the theorists of Hindutva advocate but
it was a central aim of most scientists
to separate what savarkar and goal
Walker struggled to bring together they
wanted a secular state in which
religious Jews would feel at home
but which would also include non Jews
and Jewish non-believers as equal
citizens savarkar thought of himself as
a man of the Enlightenment the secular
rationalist but he had as 'she's Nandi
rights paradoxically arrived at the
conclusion that only religion could be
an efficacious building block for
nation and state formation in South Asia
his kind of nationalism was indeed the
dark twin of religious zealotry but
throughout his life says Nandi he
remained at the margin of Indian
politics throughout the struggle for
national liberation he was a distinctly
marginal figure how then did he move
posthumous Lee into the center for the
Marxist account of national liberation
again that's not a hard question the
answer is that neighbor whose politics
was closer to serve our cars than either
of them would ever have admitted they
are each other's disowned doubles and I
want to give that argument it's due in
the Israeli and Algerian cases also so
let me acknowledge that the Jewish love
of Zion the original Holy Land was a
necessary foundation of Zionist politics
the militants of labor Zionism
secularists all could not help but evoke
that religious emotion even if they
agreed with Hillel cyclin that I quoted
this last time the same tradition that
burdens us in the Diaspora will burden
us a thousand times more in the Land of
Israel the love of Zion made the Uganda
project impossible it is powerfully
expressed in Hatikva israel's national
anthem which Arab citizens are loath to
sing since it expresses a peculiarly
Jewish longing for the Land of Israel
the case is the same in Algeria the
Arabs came to the Maghreb as a
conquering people and Islam was the
reason for the conquest and then the
ideological foundation of Arab rule
centuries later it was perhaps the
crucial reason for Algerians to identify
themselves as not French and to resist
the incorporation of Algeria into the
French Republic the politically
necessary commitment of the FLN to the
principles of Islam was far more
consequential than the movements leaders
intended their retreat on
the woman question certainly suggests
what might be called a natural drift
from national liberation to religious
revival so this is the central claim of
the Marxist account parochialism is
parochialism whether it calls itself
national or religious from a
Universalist standpoint the secular and
religious versions of India and Jewish
and Algerian nationalism are pretty much
indistinguishable they feed one another
and if the best intentions of the
secular liberation militants are
frustrated the frustration is their own
work the necessary consequence of their
nationalist commitments by contrast the
universalism of the alternative account
derives from internationalists
commitments which are based on social
classes and economic interests rather
than on nations and religions these
commitments are nicely illustrated by an
Indian historian social theorist G L
osseous who argues that the nationalist
movement precisely because of its
religious affinities prevented the
maturing of the masses and their
emergence this is him speaking and their
emergence into a new interest based
political community the much-vaunted
struggle against untouchability he
writes reduced a total struggle against
a scripted hierarchy to a nominal
symbolic struggle for a minority of
untouchable castes it's certainly true
that the caste system made and still
makes class politics difficult in India
but there is little evidence that an
uprising of all the Indian subaltern
groups was waiting to happen
but was diverted by the Congress
nationalists into a merely symbolic
campaign against untouchability the
total struggle exists that I'm afraid
more in theory than in practice or
better it should have existed and is
evoked by Marxist writers as if it
actually
did exist but any political leader in
the real world looking for the maturing
masses would have ended up not with a
social movement but with an isolated
sect the Marxist project failed or at
least has not yet succeeded though the
critique of national liberation survives
as we will see the liberationists have
not been pushed aside by the emergence
of the masses as a mature political
force nor have they been replaced in the
absence of the masses by the
revolutionary Vanguard of the global
proletariat and even if that replacement
had occurred the Vanguard militants
would have encountered the same problem
that the liberationists did they would
have found themselves at war with the
very people whose interests they claimed
to advance indeed their war might have
been even more intense and it might have
led in the case of the russian marxist
it did lead to a far more brutal
authoritarianism since it wasn't only
the religious feelings but also the
national cultural commitments of
ordinary men and women that the vanguard
militants could not or would not
acknowledge attempting to rally the
people marxist internationalists would
indeed have appealed to universal
principles rather than to archaic
emotions theirs would not have been a
parochial but rather a cosmopolitan
mobilization in their politics they
would have cultivated a new solidarity
of the oppressed across all the
boundaries of nation and religion Hindu
and Muslim Jew and Arab Algerian and
Piatt Noire would have found themselves
working together global allies against
the global axis of capitalism and
imperialism post Marxist critics of
nationalism still long for this global
alliance it's an attractive
vision so long as it's only a vision so
long as it isn't enforced
perhaps the most authentic political
representation of secularism and
enlightenment but it was never realized
and we need to reflect for a moment on
the failure of the cosmopolitan
revolutionaries and on the success
however qualified of national liberation
it's not the case that the
revolutionaries were just unlucky no
where in the world did proletarian
internationalism succeed even for a
brief time in displacing national
identification marks may have been right
about class interest but he was
certainly wrong about the relative
appeal of class-based and nation based
politics foreign rule was everywhere
experienced as a form of national
oppression in whose miseries all social
classes shared an opposition to foreign
rule cut across class lines even when it
was begun and led by upper or middle
class groups workers and peasants
eventually joined in a cosmopolitan
liberation movement may or may not come
after the triumph of national liberation
that's still an open question but there
was never a chance that it could come
before and efforts to make it come
before did not bring anything like
liberation from the failure of
internationalism and practice however it
doesn't necessarily follow that the
theoretical critique of national
liberation is wrong I suppose that the
unity of theory and practice requires us
to be skeptical now about Marxist
internationalism if the practice has
failed then the theory should be in
trouble but the critique of national
liberation is also a moral critique
which holds that the liberationists
share responsibility for all the dark
features of contemporary nationalism
including those that are marked by
religious zeal can this be right given
that national liberation was so fiercely
anti
religious it's certainly true that
secularism was something new for Indians
Jews and Algerians and the separation of
religion and politics was an artifact of
liberationist politics hence artificial
any effort to find liberationist themes
in the history of these people's moments
of independence activism solidarity and
self-sacrifice would inevitably draw on
religiously inflected events and beliefs
the collective goals of the national
liberation movements overlapped with and
were often expressed in the language of
religious hopes and dreams all that is
true on the other hand seculars
commitments did make a difference and
it's important to focus on that
difference in order to recognize the
value of the liberationist project to
its militants and to argue as I will
want to do tomorrow in the last of these
lectures that the project is worth
continuing and completing so consider
once more for the last time the Jewish
belief that the Messiah would bring the
exiled people home to the Land of Israel
this in gathering becomes a central
Zionist goal but now it is reconceived
as a political project subject to all
the normal vicissitudes of politics
requiring organization fundraising
diplomacy compromise and possibly this
was the struggle of fierce debate a
subject of fierce debates possibly the
use of force the idea of waiting for
divine deliverance was rejected and that
ideas I've already argued lay at the
heart of exilic Judaism the cases are
the same with the religious idea of
settling the land the Zionist maxim
another dunam another goat is not only a
prosaic version of this idea it's also a
transformed version focus now on human
effort and open to the necessity of
compromise
and limit the religious idea does not
admit of dividing the land but dividing
the dunams
is a real possibility of course
religious revival produces its own
transformations when Jewish zealots
entered into the practical work of
settling the land after the 1967 war
they were obviously not waiting for the
Messiah they were in the old religious
language forcing the end forcing the end
but they acted with a sense that the end
was near that they were on the brink of
messianic times the success of their
work was divinely guaranteed and so the
ideas of compromise and limit were
inconceivable to them one can argue that
the liberationists project made this
gsella tree possible and historically
that's certainly true just as one might
rightly say that the Enlightenment made
the counter Enlightenment possible but I
doubt that it's morally right to blame
the liberationists for the zealots it
would be a great mistake to ignore the
difference between the two ways of
settling the land and similarly it would
be a great mistake to ignore the
difference between the critique of
untouchability by Gandhi and Nehru
however incomplete it was and the
defense of the functional organization
of society by Hindu nationalists in
Dutra isn't implicit in and doesn't
follow from the incompleteness of the
Nehru vien critique it's more accurate
to say that it follows from the no doubt
partial success of national liberation
as Thomas Hanson has argued Hindutva is
a reaction against broad democratic
transformations of both the political
field and public culture in
post-colonial India he means egalitarian
transformations in fact the Hindu
nationalists have made good use of
democracy which has brought their
followers previously passive and
inarticulate committed to the routines
of the old religion into political life
recall Rajeev Bhargav oz explanation for
the rise of Hindu nationalism the
propensity of representative democracy
to encourage ethno-religious political
mobilization but this mobilization made
possible by democracy can be and in part
has been turned against social and
gender equality against liberation in
fact the contrasting politics of
liberation militants and religious
zealots might be described in another
way all three of these national
liberation movements and many others too
claimed that they were going to create a
democratic state and a just legal order
and in all three of them democracy and
justice were understood in standard that
is European ways I won't immediately say
Universal ways although that's what the
militants believe then probably rightly
they imitated the values of the European
enlightenment which are expressed in
Universalist terms and which certainly
set the militants against their own
peoples parochialism these were
nationalists who wanted their Nations to
measure up to principles first
established elsewhere indeed their
commitment to those principles was
probably stronger the Algerians are an
exception here than that of their
Marxist critics they wanted to join the
Society of states which in its origins
was a European society but in its
ambitions a global society they wanted
as the Zionists said to be normal by
contrast the religious zealots want to
be different
they don't aim at a state like all the
other states they want a state shaped by
their own interpretation or
reinterpretation of a particular
religious tradition and that's why they
resist the universalizing discourse of
democracy and human rights invoking
instead Hindu culture and Asian values
or Jewish or Islamic law
the same contrast can be illustrated
even with regard to the treatment of the
new minorities created by National
Liberation Muslims in India arabs and
israel Berbers in Algeria where the
Marxist critique of nationalism is
seemingly strongest the liberationists
were indeed committed first of all to
the revival of their own nation but they
were also committed to the inclusion of
the others in the state they were making
I can't argue that any of them were
successful or entirely successful in
their inclusiveness they fell far short
their politics sometimes collapsed into
nationalism Cukor but I do want to argue
that their original commitments were
significantly different from those of
the religious nationalists who came
later I'll take up the Algerian case
first the FLN was committed from the
beginning to a unitary state with full
equality for all its citizens the Summa
platform of 1956
singled out Europeans and Jews as the
future minorities that most needed to be
reassured and accommodated though
Berbers figured significantly in the
leadership of the FLN and in the
drafting of the platform nothing was
said there about autonomy or linguistic
equality for the Berber community which
turned out to be the most important
minority in the new state once
independence was one and almost all the
Europeans and Jews were gone the FLN
government first Vandellas and then boom
Aryans launched a fierce Arabization
campaign a rejection of liberation for
the sake of a straightforward
nationalism the result was a brief
uprising in kabylia the berber district
and then almost twenty years later a
berber spring the beginning of an
ongoing agitation for state recognition
of the language
culture and history of the Berber people
the FLN in power has steadily resisted
this agitation but the liberation
movement that it once was still has a
voice in Algerian politics it is
represented by the militants who found
themselves in prison or in exile in the
years after 1962 and who continued to
fight for a secular democracy Fannin
died of leukaemia in 1961 and so wasn't
among them as he might have been Hossein
eight akhmad one of the Berbers among
the historic nine the founders of the
FLN is perhaps the best spokesman for an
ongoing liberationist politics he is a
leader of I think he's recently retired
he must be in his eighties he is a
leader of the front of socialist forces
a national political party that draws
its support mainly from Kabylia aid
Achmed went into opposition and into
exile early in the history of the new
state and in the years since has
defended with great courage a secular
pluralist and democratic politics in the
local elections of 1990 in the national
elections of 91 when the Islamists swept
the country Kabylia remained a secular
stronghold and voted strongly for the
Socialist Front during the colonial
years the French touted the Berbers in
contrast to the Arabs as almost European
the natural carriers of French culture
and Algeria I'm not going to play that
game
there are many secular nationalists and
Democrats among Algerian Arabs who would
claim to descend from the original FLN
and who set themselves against Islamist
radicalism in the drafting of the
secular Zuma platform however the
initiative lay I'm quoting a historian
of the Algerian war the initiative lay
with the Berbers as opposed to the Arabs
and in the years after 1962
the Arab izing FLN regime from whose
leading positions Berbers were excluded
was not a force for liberation not for
women as we have seen and not for
minorities still still the state the FLN
created was and is a secular state and
if it were ever replaced by an Islamic
state
women would surely be worse off and the
Berbers probably so labor Zionists in
power did better than the FLN in
avoiding authoritarianism and brutality
but they too failed to live up to their
egalitarian commitments the state they
created in May of 1948 was a Jewish
state but at the same time a secular
state with the rights of national and
religious minorities guaranteed in the
Declaration of Independence Israel took
over without significant change the
millet system originally put in place by
the ottomans and maintained by the
british so arab christians and muslims
had and have their own family courts
conducted in their own language ruling
in accordance with their own religious
law but this egalitarian arrangement
which owes more to enlightened
imperialism than to national liberation
has no parallel in society or economy
where the commitment to equality was
mostly ignored the commitment
nonetheless was important it set up
barriers against the worst forms of
discrimination and abuse if one reads
and listens to the religious zealots in
israel today the difference is obvious
and it makes little sense to say that
the strength of the zealots follows
naturally from the nationalism of the
labor zionist s-- it follows instead as
in india from the democracy that the
labor Zion is created and then from
their failure to produce a strong and
coherent secular culture to go with that
democracy the zealots represent the
return of the negated or of the
not-quite negated
their opposition to equality for the
others isn't a continuation of an
earlier zionist politics but a
repudiation of it so here is David
ben-gurion speaking in late 1947 after
the UN had voted for partition he's
speaking to a meeting of my PI that is
the political party that he led and that
ruled Israel for its first first three
decades this is what he said we must
think in terms of a statement in terms
of independence in terms of full
responsibility for ourselves and for
others in our state there will be
non-jews as well and all of them will be
equal citizens equal in everything
without any exception that is the state
will be their state as well the attitude
of the Jewish state to its Arab citizens
will be an important factor in building
good neighborly relations with the Arab
states the striving for a Jewish Arab
Alliance requires us to fulfill several
obligations which we are obliged to do
in any event full and real equality day
Ouray and de facto of all the states
citizens gradual equalization of the
economic and social standards of the
Arab community with the Jewish community
recognition of the Arab language as the
language of the Arab citizens in
administration courts of justice and
above all in schools municipal autonomy
in villages and cities and so on that is
was a liberationist vision of a state at
peace with its neighbors and the
invasion of the new state in 1948 by
five Arab armies must count as one of
the reasons perhaps the crucial reason
that none of the governments over which
Ben Gurion presided lived up to the
commitments he described in that speech
the Equality he promised has never been
realized
in the 65 years of Israel's history but
it is a matter of real importance that
equality was for ben-gurion as it was
for the Algerian authors of the Summa
platform consistent with and even
required by National Liberation for it
is not required by nor is it consistent
with the religious nationalism that came
later my next and last lecture will
begin with the Indian debate about these
issues in which postmodern and
post-colonial writers have played a
major part but I want to stop here to
quote from a speech that closely
parallels ben-gurion z-- 1947 talk
delivered at the inaugural session of
the Indian Constituent Assembly where
the newly created States Constitution
was drafted the speaker is Rajendra
Prasad president of the assembly and
later the first President of India he's
responding to the boycott of the
assembly by members of the Muslim League
we who are present in the house cannot
forget even for a moment that many of
the seats are vacant at this meeting our
brethren of the Muslim League are not
with us and their absence increases our
responsibility we shall have to think at
each step what would they have done if
they had been here we hope that they
will come and take their place but if
unfortunately these seats continue to
remain unoccupied it will be our duty to
frame a constitution which will leave no
room for complaint from anybody the
promise implicit here extends beyond the
mere writing of the Constitution and
like other liberationists promises it
remains unfulfilled Muslim Indians have
many legitimate complaints but I need to
insist again that while National
Liberation may have its own failures its
own pathologies these are not the same
as or the source of the pathologies of
temporary politicized religion and
religious nationalism the test of every
national liberation movement is the
nation that comes next so the Jews are
tested by the Palestinians the Algerian
Arabs by the Berbers and the Indians by
the Muslims in their largely Hindu
nation state right now none of the three
nations is scoring very high
nevertheless the three minority groups
demonstrate the strength of the
liberationists project by imitating it
like self-determination national
liberation is a iterative process each
collective self must determine itself
each nation must liberate itself the
proletarian revolution may free all
humanity at one go but national
liberation is always partial in
particular these people free themselves
and other people looking on are invited
to do the same so labor Zionism doesn't
produce religious zealotry
we might better say that it's most
authentic project is the Palestinian
national liberation movement and
similarly the Berber Spring is the most
authentic project product of FLN
nationalism and if you are in favor of
this kind of liberation of nations or
people's one by one you must be in favor
of its repetitions it would be morally
and consistent as well as foolish to
imagine that the process stops with me
or with you and me or with us the
pathologies of religious zealot rebuy
conquests do not derive from an
inconsistent application of Hindu or
Jewish or Muslim doctrine but rather
from a passionate consistency if all
these religious groups wanted was
toleration for themselves then there
would be much like national groups
seeking liberation and they would be
bound if not
by the rule of reiteration than by the
rule of reciprocity I will tolerate you
if you will tolerate me
but toleration is not what the zealots
want they aim in each of my three cases
to create a state that is entirely their
own and to exalt their nation above all
others the passion they bring to this
effort is obviously a response to
national liberation but it is also
radically different from it thank you